à dijon reprises devant la cour
d'assises de la côte d'or du procès de
jean marie villemin
la cour et les jurés sont une nouvelle
fois parti à la chasse aux corbeaux
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan à l'extérieur du palais la
justice à des égards pour le juge
lambert mais dans la salle d'audience
personne ne le ménagent pas même le
président de la cour d'assises qui est
un moment rappelle à l'ordre le juge un
peu trop d un vol
s'il vous plaît vous voyez bien la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui un reproche à peine voilée à
la barre le juge évoque la découverte du
gendarme klein sur la lettre du 16
octobre revendiquant la mort de grégory
le gendarme nous a montré des empreintes
il y avait là un bep à peine visible et
1 l
ce fut un choc c'était une confirmation
de la piste la roche
cinq jours plus tard la roche était
inculpé et écroué
nombreux sont les experts qui se sont
penchés sur les enregistrements du
corbeau pour certains leurs expertises
ont été annulées faute de procédure
imputable au juge d'instruction
cet après midi ils sont quatre à
réentendre le corbeau pour eux il s'agit
d'une voix traînante chuchotait déguisé
grand guignol pour les quatre experts
cela ressemble à une voix féminine une
journée une de plus qui ne peut que
laisser perplexe les jurés un corbeau
par téléphone identifié comme étant
plutôt une femme
un corbeau épistolaire et une empreinte
qui accable bernard laroche et les jurés
de se poser une question at-on affaire
un corbeau à deux têtes
autrement dit faut-il dans le dossier
grégory prendre au sérieux l'hypothèse
d'une complicité